[Musique]
avec sa plume
l'acteur jim carrey sert à boulet rouge
sur donald trump
il publie ensuite et dessins sur son fil
twitter suivi par 18 millions d'abonnés
on veut susciter le dialogue on veut que
les gens réfléchissent
c'est pas chez nous chez nos voisins du
sud
est ce qu'un jour ça pourrait être chez
nous le centre fuit lieu qui conjugue
les arts et la technologie regroupe une
cinquantaine de ses oeuvres dans une
exposition inspirée par l'actualité
il réagit entre autres au recul en
démocratie aux restrictions du droit à
l'avortement et à la violence et un
point de vue au niveau politique
une geste politique comme dans notre
tradition de ne juge pas ces sujets en
fait qu'ils jugent seller leur innocence
et leur inconscience très impliqué
l'acteur a choisi minutieusement tous
les dessins tout comme le titre de
l'exposition des slides never goes out
qu'on pouvait traduire par cette lumière
ne s'éteindra jamais ne pas se laisser
endormir de de toujours être alerte et
demain de réagir à ce qui se passe mais
john kerry ne fait pas que de la satire
il exprime aussi son admiration pour les
grands disparus comme le scientifique
stephen hawking aretha franklin et robin
williams je voulais juste avoir le
contraste en sortant de l'exposition que
que l'artiste a fait un geste
d'amour ça donne un peu un cours
d'actualité sans heurts a tout à fait je
pense que je pense qu'il ne va pas
ralentir on est quand même un an et demi
des prochaines présidentielles aux états
unis l'artiste at il l'intention de
venir faire son tour potentiellement
leçon l'espère vraiment l'expo l'est
jusqu'au début septembre avec ses
dessins engagé jim carrey fait la
démonstration qu'il est un artiste
complet celui qui nous a fait rire aux
éclats au cinéma nous fait maintenant
rires gendre avec ses dessins une
nécessité ici julie jasmin boudreau
radio canada montréal